So plastics.
Plastics come in all shapes,
forms and colors.
They are everywhere.
They are in our makeup,
it packages our food
and insulates our homes.
They are in airplanes
and our favorite electronic devices.
They are truly a remarkable material.
But so are its troubles.
And we produce and consume plastics
in staggering quantities.
Since it's been mass-produced,
the world has created
over 10 billion metric tons of it.
Half of them just in the past 20 years.
I have been investigating
plastic pollution [for] about a decade,
and I try to align my personal
choices as a consumer
with the aspirations of my research.
And you may think, “Oh, that’s easy,
you know how to do it.”
But actually it’s not.
Sometimes it's impossible
to avoid single-use plastics.
The system is built that way.
The dominant narrative about plastics
tell us that this is a consumer’s
and a waste management problem.
Who of us here have not heard
about the tales
of gigantic plastic islands
floating in the middle of the ocean?
Which, by the way, it's not true.
And that low-income countries are to blame
for most of the plastic waste
entering our oceans.
But this narrative is a misleading
oversimplification
of a much bigger and complex story.
Plastics and their chemical additives
are really a climate problem.
Now, we need to think of plastics
from a systemic perspective.
So let me take you through
the journey of plastics.
Plastics contribute to climate change
from before the moment they are produced
to long beyond the moment
they are disposed or landfill
or drift into the ocean.
And it will remain
in the environment for centuries,
degrading ecological processes.
For 99 percent of all plastics
the starting point
is fossil fuel hydrocarbons.
Oil, gas and coal are extracted
and refined to produce plastic
and other synthetic chemicals.
And those processes generate greenhouse
gases such as CO2 and methane.
Studies indicate that if nothing is done,
the production of single-use plastic alone
will contribute to more than 10 percent
of all greenhouse gas emissions by 2050.
And the thing is that our use of plastic
last often just a few minutes
or a few hours,
then we throw them away,
and that generates further emissions.
And we know that our recycling
system doesn't work.
It's broken everywhere.
And recycling plastics is hard
and not cost-competitive.
Most of the waste
that has not been landfilled
or incinerated domestically
is shipped across the planet,
and it reaches low-income countries
where they are expected to be recycled.
But this is one of those
hypocrisies of globalization
where rich countries outsource
their problems to low-income countries.
And we know that these countries
do not have the capacity
nor the technology to deal with them
in a soundly manner.
And so huge amounts of plastics
are illegally incinerated,
informally dumped or get lost at sea.
And as a result,
millions of tons of plastic every year
get into our environment.
But even plastics that are soundly managed
emit greenhouse gases.
Once plastics enter the environment,
landfill, are dispersed in soil or water,
they start a process of breaking down
into micro and nanoparticles.
I will just call them microplastic
for the sake of the conversation today.
And this process of breaking down
emits powerful gases such as methane,
ethylene and CO2.
And that's true for both traditional
and biodegradable plastics.
On the surface of microplastics,
new microbial communities can grow.
We call them the plastisphere.
And their biological activity
also releases additional CO2
and nitrous oxide into the environment,
creating the possibility of further
magnifying the climate problem.
It means that microplastic
can also impair the growth
and the photosynthesis capacity
of phytoplankton,
which are the microorganisms producing
much of the oxygen we breathe.
But also microplastics
can have toxic effects on zooplankton,
and the health of these organisms
[is] essential for the functioning
of all aquatic food webs.
And unfortunately, the problems
run even deeper.
Microplastics bind with
the so-called marine snow,
which are made out
of the clumps of bacteria,
plankton and other organic material
that sinks down into the ocean depth,
acting like a biological carbon pump.
But microplastics risk
affecting this marine snow
and potentially decreasing
the capacity of the ocean
to absorb and sequester carbon
from the atmosphere.
And microplastics can be decreasing
the reflective properties of snow and ice,
potentially accelerating the melting
of glaciers and polar ice.
So we have early enough indications
that plastic pollution is starting
to change the processes
that allow the Earth's
climate system to work.
And this pollution is not
a localized phenomenon.
Microplastics are everywhere,
from the mountaintops of Everest
to the deepest sediment
in the Mariana Trench.
They are in the air we breathe,
the water we drink and the food we eat.
They are now found
in our bloodstream and our lungs.
And personally, the most terrifying,
in the placenta of our unborn children.
Now, of course, plastic
is a great material,
it's versatile and durable,
and in many ways it has allowed
modern civilization
to develop in the way it has.
But it also comes with a lot of problems
and the outlook is worrying.
Today, the total mass of plastic
is twice the total mass
of all living organisms on the planet.
But still, fossil fuel companies
see hydrocarbon as their
primary growth sector
projecting a 30 percent increase
of virgin plastic
for single-use plastic
just in the next five years.
We already see an accelerating pace
in producing and releasing new chemicals
because there are many,
many kinds of plastic.
Each one the result of a different
chemical formula.
And we know that this is incompatible
with staying within the safe
operating space for humanity.
And given how plastics impact the climate
and the world's social ecological system,
this would spell a catastrophe.
By the way, I'm not saying
that we are completely doomed yet.
There are solutions.
And it’s that worldwide,
entrepreneurs and companies
are creating new designs and material
that can substitute
traditional single-use plastic.
And social movements are consolidating
and educating people
to reduce their plastic footprint
and pressuring local
and world policy makers
to enact strong policies.
And scientists are
collaborating more than ever,
communicating the urgency
to limit not only the volume,
but the chemical diversity of plastics.
And earlier this year,
representatives from over 170 nations
at the UN Environment Assembly
adopted an initiative
to end plastic pollution,
committing all these countries
to participate in creating, by 2024,
a legally binding agreement
that addresses the full
life cycle of plastics,
from production to design
to disposal.
We need to stop thinking of plastic
just as a waste problem,
one that can be solved by changing
consumers's habits alone
and stopping using plastic bags.
We need to think of plastics
as a climate problem,
as a product that creates damage
along all its journey,
from the drilling up of hydrocarbons
to the spread of microplastics.
And that can only be addressed
in a systemic way.
Thank you.
(Applause)